hallo mein name ist wo komm wir spielen
heute das beste spiel aller zeiten eine
unglaubliche story dieses spiel ist
einfach so unfassbar gut und zwar ist es
facebook laut der facebook pages dieses
spiel das brand new top real time
strategy award game auf 2015 mich
angeschrieben ob ich das nicht
vielleicht beim zocken will ja wir
starten direkt rein und zwar ist das
clash of kings ja komm du das mit sogar
mitteilung sind okay hier das ist unser
doch wieso brennen unser dorf wie kommt
so vollzog
wir leben die glaub ich nicht so im
frieden alle mit konstanz daten ein die
kämpfen gegen meine stadt oder ich
kämpfe gegen die oder alt oder was wenn
nur der feind eurodis hübsch und wir
haben ein sägewerk level 1 gebaut lasst
uns unser holz benutzen um einen stall
zu bauen das heißt nichts was wir machen
ist hier draufklicken und wir bauen
einen stall das ist zumindest gut dass
es ganz toll erklärte fließt und blöd in
solchen anderen spielt mein lauert wir
brauchen einen acker na gut fräulein
dann bauen wir natürlich auch noch ein
acker alles was die frauen wollen ich
weiß halt nur noch dass es bei den
anderen spielen damals immer so war
irgendwie was habe ich da gespielt die
stämme habe ich mal kurzzeitig gespielt
oder die siedler da war es immer so blöd
decke nein ich gebe nicht mein facebook
password einem gerade ist der schönste
satz in einem kriegsspiel gefallen
wir können jetzt mit der ausbildung von
truppen beginnen musik ist nice
chemische mucke sondern bilden wir uns
mal so ein paar truppen hier aus bous
drei minuten das lasst uns jetzt eine
kaserne bauen infanteristen das sind
nochmal infanteristen als infanterie
oder fußtruppe bezeichnet man sich zu
fuß bewegende und kämpfen damit
handwaffen ausgerüstete soldaten der
boden streitkräfte alles klar was kann
mein lord jetzt können wir die welt der
kunden hat sie gerade gesagt das heißt
wir entdecken jetzt willkommen im
ausland was wollen die alle in meiner
burg okay wir startet unseren ersten
angriff meine truppen gehen jetzt los
auf diesen acker da vorne ja truppen
brauchen einige zeit das ist mir auch
schon aufgefallen das schiff wir dir
nützliche items für anfänger bringen
hatte mich gerade anfänger genannt
fräulein ich bin profi na es ist
erntezeit
wir können unsere tollen dachten
abfahren dadurch haben wir jetzt wieder
neues neue rohstoff und aus dem neuen
rohstoffen können wir jetzt unsere burg
verbessern ja das war das wo ich mich
auf clevelands immer darauf konzentriert
hat nur diese scheiß auf gebäude in der
mitte zu updaten
es war halt echt zu meine taktik damals
bei coc war dass ich die besten mauern
habe und das ging nur dadurch dass du
das hauptgebäude geupdatet hast aber wir
spielen hier gerade nicht leicht klein
sondern clash of kings und wir
verbessern jetzt erstmal die burg auf
der welt auch gott vier minuten so soll
eine sägemühle bauen alter wo ist denn
die ziegel bühne hier hat er das hier
war nur ein segen
wer keine segel baumann sägewerker
bessere mauer auf level 2
in dem spiel ist gerade genau so ein
wetter wie bei uns draußen wenn ich grad
mal raus gucke es regnet
und regnet der bauer ein scheiß schießt
alles klar
lesen muss gelernt sein luca ok nachdem
ich jetzt diese ganzen sachen hier
eigentlich nach und nach verbessert habe
kommen das lager könnte auch noch mal
eben auf level 2 hier verbessert so ich
habe nur angst dass meine münzen gleich
wechsel würde ich das hier die ganze
zeit schon schneller machen wir klicken
mal einfach auf quests und zwar haben
wir da wir können uns belohnen ab
holweger dieses gadget goalgetter es
regnet hier gold für mich man freunde
das ist ja unfassbar kommen gibt mir
noch mehr was habt ihr denn noch alles
für mich freunde immer mehr belohnungen
yaman alter ist regnet quasi holztüre
das ja unfassbar
ich bin ja wirklich ein profi und das
habe ich wirklich nicht so viel gemacht
aber die belohnung hören einfach nicht
aufbauen lasst uns lernen wie man
gegenstände benutzt
alles klar da ich die ganze zeit weiter
reden findet ihr das gut ein anfänger
geschenk alter ich krieg hier dieses
spiel besteht daraus dass sie dir alles
schenken ich habe locker eine millionen
geschenke gerade bekommen dabei
nachrichten bekommen von verschiedenen
leuten hier
ich habe schon wieder eine belohnung
bekommen zehn miliz ausbildet perfekter
form jetzt mal wieder weiter in das
kampf regime miliz kommen und machen wir
mal genau hier kommen wir haben doch
genug dann 120 miliz so die miliz ist
fertig ausgebildet dann können wir hier
noch weitere leute aus unglaublich weil
ich habe keine lust nur die milizen
machen immer mehr noch wenn kaserne
level 4 erreicht auch erst noch einen
dritten ackerbau neues klassen schon
genug holz oder so wir haben 37 1000
holz und die sagen mir ich muss noch
mehr holz haben ich kann hier eine
allianz beitreten um dadurch gold zu
erhalten nicht einfach mal in die
obersten und klick auf beitreten
du bist der allianz wea legions
beigetreten
dass dies meine truppe kann ich jetzt
hier machen
mama allianz schlacht geht das diese
sind wir in frieden man es gibt aktuell
keine allianz krieg aufzeichnungen
maria levels wenn ihr das seht das mag
ich würde sagen das wars mit der ersten
folge von clash of klingt wenn ihr
möchtet dass ich davon zweiten teil
gerade weil die erste folge weil es
erstmal so jo wir kommen rein wie geht
das ganze auch immer dann verbessere ich
meine stadt hier auch nochmal die region
hier vorne ist einfach wieder befüllen
paket zusammengefasst kann man sagen
dass dieser erste teil ist bisher nur
daraus bestand so ein bisschen dorf
aufzubauen und so weiter und so fort und
aus einem millionen belohnungen etwa
wenn ihr eventuell irgendwann zweiten
teil möchte wo ich ein bisschen kämpfe
weil ehrlich gesagt macht mir das sogar
spaß obwohl ich eigentlich nicht so der
fan von sowas bin zwar hinter möchte
zeigt mit einer bewertung ihr findet was
download link ist in der beschreibung
ja das bauhaus und dann sehen wir uns
dann wieder wenn ihr mich wieder sehen
möchtet